Actually, I'm learning English because it will be helpful for my career.
I'm learning English because first of all, I want to be a teacher of English in my country.
I would like to work for some companies who work in Canada and USA...
...and they need really good English skills,...
...and I have to speak English very well, and work for them.
Well, I believe that English is very important nowadays...
...as you cannot continue studying without using English 'cause it's the international language nowadays.
I'm learning English because I love it.
I love the English culture, the American culture, its movie, its music.
English is a world language, so we need to study English.
It's essential and personally, I wanna be a politician...
...or I wanna be a diplomat, which my father wants.
So, I think English is the most important thing for a politician or a diplomat.